and for more now on the state of the war
in Ukraine we are joined by CBS News
foreign policy and National Security
contributor retired lieutenant general
H.R mcnaster a person you may know as
the former National Security advisor in
the Trump Administration uh General
thank you for being here this is a war
that has lasted way longer than a lot of
people thought who has the upper hand
right now well Tony I don't think
anybody has really a clear upper hand
but I think the ukrainians have time on
their side I think what you've seen with
the Russians is they just can't generate
the combat power to sustain an offensive
you know they've lost maybe 2 000 tanks
they've had maybe 200 000 casualties and
even though they've thrown in these new
con these new conscript troops into the
fight they're not quipped they're not
trained and they're not having success
in these in this this Russian
counter-offensive you know which was a
big deal made out of it but but it's
actually failing so people are thinking
the weather's going to warm and as the
temperature goes up the war is going to
change what are you expecting from the
springtime okay what you're seeing now
is you're already seeing the the counter
offensive begin and and uh and and this
is the Russian renewed offensive I
should say in in the in the provinces of
donesk and and uh lujans Mohawks is the
main effort mainly around this town of
bakmut and what you've seen are these
really World War one style attacks to
try to turn the ukrainians uh out of out
of their positions but you know even if
they get like a small local success in
Baku you've got a big Ridge line here
and you've got a river so the ukrainians
have established a defense in depth and
you know the Russians are running out of
material they're scrambling for
ammunition they were firing 60 000
rounds a day again World War One like
tactics bombardment and infantry attacks
yeah and now they're firing only 20 000
a day that's a big change there it's a
big change and there are some supporting
attacks going on down here toward the
Ukraine's but Ukraine are easily
defeating these so the big question is
you know as as as Russia trades
thousands of casualties for hundreds of
meters of ground how only can they
sustain that yeah and then the question
of supplies as well that point actually
let's walk back to the table because
something that's front page news as we
speak is the question of whether China
will start providing lethal Aid to
Russia in the form of weapons that's the
reporting at least from our intelligence
Community is allegedly finding that what
do you know what do you make of those
developers and Putin said that they are
reaching new Milestones
um with with the China Diplomat that is
there absolutely with wangi visiting uh
visiting Putin and providing you know
his pledge for continued support I think
the important point is China is already
supporting Russia's War making machine
they're buying 60 percent more oil from
Russia than they were before the renewed
invasion of a year ago so they're
feeding you know Putin's ATM that he
needs to keep the war going they also
are providing microelectronics and other
materials that have led the U.S Commerce
Department to Blacklist a large number
of Chinese companies already so the
question is she and she's you know court
right now is do you want to go all in
with Russia and really risk and
accelerate rending of the U.S financial
and economic relationship with China
because I think that's that's what's in
the cards if they do provide is it not
in China's interest to keep uh Russia at
war with with us uh and keep us uh
United with us with Ukraine but keep us
uh pumping money and weapons in that
direction isn't that in their interest
well you could say that this is
depleting you know our war stocks but I
think we're now mobilizing finally to
expand production of Munitions and and
of weapon systems that are really
critical for the ukrainians I don't
think Russia can keep up with it I mean
they're actually you know they're trying
desperately to buy more from the
Iranians I mean there are rumors now and
I think these are these are true that
they're they're now getting artillery
ammunition from Iran as well as the
drones that you've seen uh them
providing I think missiles are probably
next uh in terms of what Iran could
provide they're buying ammunition from
North Korea they're trying they're
scrambling to get whatever they can and
if China comes in with Munitions is what
they really need they need you know they
need the components too right I mean
Russia can only build about 40 cruise
missiles a month and they fire 40 cruise
missiles just in one of the salvos that
they've been using to attack the
Ukrainian people and and the
infrastructure but this all started with
Vladimir Putin do you see any scenario
where he could be removed from power is
there anything more the U.S needs to do
should be doing or others should be
doing you know Gail it's it's tough to
see I think the most important thing at
this stage is to poke holes in Russia's
information firewall because you saw the
big speech the Putin gave a day ago and
he's still out of touch with reality
right and and it's important to get you
know to get the Russian people
alternative sources of information an
encouraging statistic is at the
beginning of this war about 30 percent
of the people who used to get their
information exclusively from Russian
television are now getting it from some
other sources as well like telegram
channels and other source of information
on the internet there are some some you
know some opposition groups yeah uh that
are that are that are using telegram
channels another means to reach more of
the of the of the Russian people with
reality with the truth General H.R
McMaster thank you so much we appreciate
you